We have already seen that a VLIW instruction
really specifies several operations. Each of which operations would
have taken a normal instruction in a normal super
scalar processor. The instructions set for a VLIW processor
typically has all the normal ISA opcodes, so
each of the VLIW instructions can typically do whatever
normal instructions would have been able to do in
and out of normal processor. A typical VLIW processor
will also have support for full predication, or
at least very extensive predication support. This is
because it relies on the compiler to expose
parallelism. One of the ways the compiler does that
is through scheduling instructions, so we really want
the compiler to be able to predicate and thus
expose more opportunities for instruction scheduling. A VLIW
ISA also, typically, includes a lot of architectural registers.
The reason for this is at that a lot
of the scheduling optimizations require use of additional registers. We
have already seen some examples of this in the
compiler support for IOP lesson. What we have seen, that
sometimes we have to put somethings in other registers,
when we're rearranging instructions. So to help the compiler do
instruction scheduling, we need more registers than usual and we
really, really want the compiler to do a god job
here so we will provide a lot of
registers to it. Another frequently seen type of
ISA support for compiler work are the branch
hints, where the compiler can specify to the hardware
what it thinks the branches will do. This
helps the branch vectors. And we also often
see some sort of compaction mechanism for VLIW
instructions. For example, if we have a four operation
instruction, and we have something like this, we do
some operation and then the next operation needs to
be here and thus we have to put NOPs
in here. The actual VLIW instruction might include some sort
of a stop date for every instruction, in which
case we can put OP1 here, then mark this
as a stop, and then we can put OP2, and OP3, like this, mark this as a stop, and
even squeeze in maybe something else here. So,
the idea is that instead of having a lot
of NOPs in our instruction, now the processor
fetches this instruction, checks for the stop bits, and
in the first cycle does this, in the second cycle does up to the next stop and
so on. So, this helps a lot in reducing
the number of NOPs and thus, the code bloat